[Music]
oh [__] I gotta fix the screen hold on
we're down here in Mobile Alabama uh we
thought we were coming to some kind of
roller skating event but all we got was
game shift there's a
yes that's a great start
mythical but your Nancy's in the chat
right now too [__] drag show over
there with a bunch of kids cool
what the [__] going on
[__] moat in Alabama all right
oh look we edited this
he made this music for this yeah
Jesus Christ oh my god oh [__] he saw
that furry
[Music]
Jesus ladies Who's hotter white man or
black man it all depends depends on all
right hey all right girl all right all
right I like her and I bet you they
don't like the gay [__] what
how he built how he built so you don't
really have a you don't care as long as
he fine yeah that's right what do you
think about me
thank you
[Laughter]
black girls are black girls black and
white both I love them all
this guy is so far my favorite man
that's that's actually whenever I talk I
asked Merce that same question when he's
drunk and he says the same thing
my girl's a black girls
both I love them
that was immersed in the streets of
Austin
black or white announcing it to anyone
who would listen
I'm like merch you're yelling at a
police horse
well he's listening
Who's hotter white men or black men
what do you like better
[Music]
Who's hotter white man that's black man
better black man
white man oh [__] oh
hey
thank you black man oh come on I like
light-skinned men though like I'm I'm
skinned black girls like what about
light-skinned white dudes not light skin
white dudes white dudes with hands you
don't like them milk they are very sexy
in their own way oh man y'all I can
think of a few very unsexy dudes I can
think of a very very lot of unsexy dudes
but in every tone
there are sexy it's so funny because we
that's why I love these videos a great
job but these are always great white
pills for Fridays because like you
realize the world is not Twitter and not
the like this is the real world right
where people don't really care that much
about them there's none of this [__]
like I mean anyone who's you know not on
the internet all the time realizes
perpetually online who goes out on any
weekend night and just has a few drinks
around yeah so people knows this is not
the real world I hear you
different man only because it seems like
they have a better sense of care
when it comes to women I treat women
better right I feel like white men treat
women better oh God this feeling I love
this
man I don't care what color they are all
right Marsh which one merge right or
left
left he's Gonna Save Me life you guys
all want mythical vigilante that's super
weird but all right man he's the white
one there
[Music]
no matter what color they are imma just
say I love some chocolate
I'm sorry okay all right
we got you both on tape even though even
though you know
ladies Who's hotter white men or black
man oh
black
black man
I don't like y'all
that was great
it's on Rumble actually white boy summer
is here again yeah
what a great time for that uh
Who's hotter white women or black women
oh
women oh come on you gotta pick one I
ain't gonna do that you're with a white
girl you say white right yeah that's
like everything on her
white women are black women Who's hotter
white girls or black girls
um come on oh you guys are all [__]
piano be honest Who's hotter white girls
or black girls Hispanic women the
interest Hispanic women it's the third
option
I'm very third position on this
uh in my opinion white girls that's just
a preference though are you racist no
you're
New York you're such an [__] very
funny though what an answer y'all don't
believe them black girls black girls are
you saying that because you don't want
to be perceived as racist now no okay
ma'am Who's hotter who do you like
better white men or black men I don't do
men at all women then you prefer white
women or black women I like hot women
fellas Who's hotter white girls or black
girls I don't like either I like Asians
anime black guys holding a trans flag
for some reason
well because that's what he thinks this
is like no he just thinks he thinks
that's that's a set piece from One Piece
actually I'm not a fetish it's not a
fetish it's just a preference okay okay
but no there's nothing right just white
girls you're racist
[Laughter]
bro mythical you've been on fire with
these bro seriously I know they've been
great questions
Who's hotter white girls or black girls
I'm attracted to men
I'm attracted to men Roll Tide do you
hear that Alabama fans you're all [__]
why did he like walk away like all man
that's defended by the question because
yeah and he's on Reddit
all you do is like any normal like
there's plenty of like cool normal gay
guys out there that if MV went up and
was like hey what do you like black
women or white women like they'd be like
I [__] dudes bro and they wouldn't like
run away and cry no but again try to see
what you would say to that and MB
probably be like all right find it but
black dudes are white dudes uh
do me a fine and black dudes give me the
clip of him saying I like men Roll Tide
so I can send it to Nick Saban that [__]
Nick Saban send it to any Alabama
oh yes it is I love to Sparkle Who's
hotter white man or black man black what
do you like better white guys wow she
was she wanted none of him okay these
women are gonna say black guys
been with
[Music]
yeah it's a hard question to answer your
face on camera because you're [__]
Alabama that's gonna be yeah
Alabama man Alabama dad
[Music]
they're black men better
black man oh my feelings are hurt he's
holding a pizza while he's doing it I
love him I love him
ladies y'all like white men or black men
better
oh
she's only saying that because she has
black friends God damn it Paul's coming
honey all the racist
I love this is great you like white men
or black men
white men
okay here we go here we go
really so I have a chance
yeah hell yeah what's your number
you gonna give it to me I already have
it [__]
damn
man MP Bro you've been these are great
man he's been he's been killing it with
this these are crazy
uh let me let me post a link in there
because you guys have to subscribe to
him his videos are [__] amazing uh
he's in the chat right now go give him a
sub game symbol these videos have been
just just fire how many Subs we had we
had now four 11 411 come on man let's
get them all let's get him be some more
stuff that up we can pump those numbers
up